- Madame Jami avait bien mis
20 ans pour rattraper le retard
imposé par la première mouture
d'un gouvernement taliban.
"Quand aiaiais petite,
la situation ne m'a pas permis
d'étudier, les écoles étaient
fermées. Nous vivions sous
les règles sévères
des talibans."
Mais avec la constance
du jardinier, celle qui était
ilrérérée est devenue éduquée.
Femme et seule, elle s'est
lancée en affaires.
"Mon entreprise de produits
alimentaires était une source
directe et indirecte de revenus
pour une centaine d'employ
Une source de revenus et
de fierté, mais avec le retour
au pouvoir des talibans,
ce n'était plus possible."
"Ce n'est possible de faire
des affaires en se cachant
ou en se couvran
Vous ne pouvez pas faire
des affaires en portant
la burqa. Personne ne nous
encourage ou ne nous soutient.N"
Ce qui lui reste de marinade,
d'épices et d'herbes séchées
accumulent la poussière chez
elle.
"Ils sont ignorants. Ils ne
savent rien. Ils ont vécu dans
les montagnes, et gardé leurs
femmes comme des esclaves."
Dans le centre commercial
réservé aux femmes qu'elle
a fondé avec l'aide de dons
étrangers, une boutique sur
deux est fermée, et les clientes
se font rares pour celles
qui s'accrochent.
C'est ici que Fawzia propose
des services de couture. On sent
toute l'amertume de cette femme,
bachelière, souligne-t-elle,
qui n'a d'autre choix
aujourd'hui pour soutenir
une famille entière.
Elle ne compte plus
ce qu'elle a perdu
avec l'arrivée au pouvoir
des talibans. Son fils aîné
est mort, l'autre se cache
à la maison. Son mari aussi,
après avoiisisisisisisonné
six mois par les nouveaux
souverains. Ses deux filles
n'ont plus droit
à une éducation.
"Je suis la seule à pouvoir
soutenir ma famille alors que
nous souffrons d'une situation
désastreuse. Nous ne sommes pas
en sécurité."
La peur au ventre ne la quitte
jamais. Elle tend les mainslllls
à calmer les tremblements.
"Nous sommes prisonnières
d'une situation sans fuite
possible. Nous y sommes
coincées physiquement,
mais aussi mentalement.
Toutes les femttttttt
de dépression et nous avons
mal."
La dépression, c'est un mot
qui revient souvent dans
les conversations avec
les femmes afghanes. Maismalgrée
elles continuent de vouloir
envoyer un message clair
aux talibans :
"Malgré toutes les répressions,
vous ne parviendrez pas à nous
faire reculer complètement
20 ans derrière." Et c'est
un message qu'elles envoient
d'abord ici dans la ru
On les croise un peu à Herat
près de l a a a a a a avec
l'Iran, mais surtout dans
les rues grouillantes de Kaboul.
Elles ont le visage découvert,
parfoi e e e e e e e elles n'ont
pas l'intention de se couvrir
plus qu'elles ne le font déjà.
Une forme de résistance
à l'imposition décrétéepapapapa.
"Il n'y a pas de mei
hijab que ça. Nous avons
des problèmes plus importants.
Il n'y a pas de travail pour
les gens, les talibans devraient
oioioioioioioiois,
ils ne paient pas les salaires."
Selon le décret émis par
les talibans, ces femmes
qui refusent de se conformer
à une tenue islamique qui est
selon eux correcte, c'est-à-dire
qu'elle couvre tout le visage
sauf les yeux, exposent
les hommlllllllllllllllllles
à la prison.
Ce code vestimentaire
ueueueueueueueueue la dernière
des restrictions de plus en
plus sévères imposées
aux femmes afghanes.èèèèèèèèès s
de la vie politique et de
la fonction publique, ils
ont aussi empêché les femmes
de monter à bord de vols
nationaux ou internationaux
sans un "mahram", un tuteur
masculin.
Ce n'est pas son métier,
mais après avoir perdu
son travail de bureau et
renoncé à se présenter en classe
voyait pas rester cloîtrée
à la maison à ne rien faire.
Lentntntntntntntntntnt
respecter et défendre les droits
des femmes. Azita les voit
plutôt disparaître un à un.
"Comment peuvent-ils prétendre
défendre le droit des femmes?
L'éducation est la base
de nos droits, comme pour
les hommes. L'éducation
d'une femme est essentielle
pour la société, les familles
ont beququququququququququées."
Elle donne de son temps
pour enseigner clandestinement
à des femmes analphabètes,
et surtout à ses filles.
Celles à qui les talibans
interdisent désormais
l'accès aux bancs d'école.
- Good morning.
"On voit le désir et l'intérêt
des filles pour leurs études.
Chacune d'entre elle avaitaiaian
qu'elles avaient a été anéantie
lorsque les écoles ont fermé."
Cela fait maintenant 267 jours
que les filles sont évincées
de l'école dès la sixième
Malgré les promesses répétées
du gouvernement taliban de
s s s s s s s s s s s les class,
c'est maintenant une année
scolaire complète dont elles
ont été privées.
Dounia parcourt des kilomètres
pour venir ici, malgré
l'interdiction.
"Pourquoi devrais-je avoir peur?
Le temps d'étudier, c'est
maintenant. Si on ne le fait
pas maintenant, nous s
vieilles et nous ne pourrons
pas poursuivre notre éducation."
"Les derniers résistants
de l'Afghanistan, ce sont
les femmes", disent celles
qui ont bien voulu se confier.ce
jour au présent, déterminées
à sauver leur avenir.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Kaboul